اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
جوانبه نبدا بالعناوين اللغه
ويعلنوا تاجيل التعديلات مع مناقشتها مره
اخرى في الصيف
قاده الاحتجاجات في اسرائيل يعتبرون تاجيل
التعديلات القضائيه مناوره ويؤكدون بقائهم
في الشوارع
[تصفيق]
امام مئات القضايا التي يواجهها الرئيس
الامريكي السابق ترامب لديه استراتيجيه
تشتيت ومواطنه
وتتابعون معنا ايضا
ورقه الانتخابات تدفع برلمانيين اوروبيين
لمعارضه حضرتك
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا اذا نبدا هذه النشره
بهذه اللقطات التي وصلتنا منذ قليل من تل
ابيب لمتظاهرين من اليمين يشتبكون مع
الشرطه احتجاجا على تعليق التعديلات
القضائيه وكان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين
نتنياهو قال اليوم بخطاب متلفز انه سيرجى
التعديلات القضائيه الى الدوره
البرلمانيه المقبله
رغبه منه في منع الانقسام في الامه وفق
قوله
نتنياهو في مواجهه الجميع هذا ما يمكن ان
نقوله على ما يحدث في اسرائيل 12 اسبوعا
مرت منذ بدايه الاحتجاجات في الشارع كانت
تزيد شدتها بين الحين والاخر لكن لا شيء
مثل الامس واليوم رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو وجد ان الضغوط عليه ليست كافيه
فزادها بنفسه على نفسه باقاله وزير الدفاع
لتنتفض الشوارع الاسرائيليه ضده الضغط كان
كبيرا لذلك خرج نتنياهو في كلمه
للاسرائيليين قبل قليل ردح للمطالب واعلن
ارجاء التعديلات القضائيه مع مناقشتها في
الدوره القادمه من الكنيست لكن مع مرور
الاسابيع تغيرت المطالب في الشارع من
المطالبه بوقف مشروع الاصلاح القضائي الى
المطالبه برحيل نتنياهو نفسه
[موسيقى]
سنعطي فرصه لتمرير التعديلات القضائيه عبر
اجماع واسع لذا قررت تاجيل التعديلات
القضائيه لهذه الدوره من الكنيست حتى نصل
لاجماع لدينا اغلبيه في الكنيست تجعلنا
نناقش التعديلات القضائيه وستتم مناقشه
التعديلات القضائيه في الدوره القادمه من
الكنيست اود الاشاره الى اني حصلت على
موافقه اغلبيه زملاء في الحكومه لمنع
الحرب الاهليه عبر الحوار هذه الازمه
تجبرنا على التصرف بمسؤوليه
[موسيقى]
بنيامين نتنياهو من مواليد تل ابيب عام
سياسي اسرائيلي يراس حزب الليكود تولى
رئاسه الحزب عام
تولى رئاسه الوزراء بين عامي
1996 وحتى
1999 واصبح اصغر رئيس وزراء في تاريخ
اسرائيل تولى المنصب مره اخرى من 2009 الى
2021 يعتبر صاحب اطول مده كرئيس حكومه في
تاريخ اسرائيل اصبح مجددا رئيسا للوزراء
في التاسع والعشرين من ديسمبر من عام 2022
اذا تراجع نتنياهو وارجو التعديلات نعم
لكن وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه تحدثت عن
صفقه نتنيه الطفقه مع وزير الامن الداخلي
اتمار بن غفير على تاجيل التعديلات حتى
جلسات الكنيست الصيفيه لكن ماذا حصل وعلى
ماذا حصل من خفيف المقابل وافق مقابل
تمرير انشاء حرس وطني واخضاعه لبن غفير
وهو امر كان يتعهد به وزير الامن القومي
قبل توليه منصبه من اجل شرعنه البؤر
الاستيطانيه غير القانونيه بضفه
[موسيقى]
بالحديث عن وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
اتمار بن اخفير اكد الاخير انه في تصريحات
طبعا وسط انصار واننا نتنياهو وعده بان
يتم تمرير التعديلات خلال اشهر من الان
ومشيرا الى انه بحلول هذا الوقت لن تكون
هناك اي حلول وسط وانه سيتم تنفيذ اراده
الاغلبيه
طبعا الصفقه التي تحدثت عنها وسائل
الاعلام رغم ان نتنياهو عان ضغطا اخر من
الاحزاب التي تمثل اقصى اليمين في الحكومه
قبل خطاب نتنياهو قال حزب الصهيونيه
الدينيه الذي يتزعمه وزير الماليه بتسئيل
ان التراجع عن التعديلات القضائيه يعني
الاستسلام لفاشيه الاقليات بحسب تعبيره
اما بعد الخطاب فوصف القراره بالخاطئ لكنه
اكد في الوقت نفسه احترام قرار نتنياهو
وقبل ذلك دعا اتمار من غفير انصاره الى
تنظيم ومظاهرات مضاده في القدس وهو نفس ما
دعى اليه
ايها الرفاق اصلاح النظام القضائي وتعزيز
الديمقراطيه يجب الا يتوقف تحت اي ظرف نحن
الاغلبيه ويجب ان لا نستسلم للعنف والفوضى
والرفض نحن الاغلبيه لنجعل صوتنا مسموعا
سنلتقي الليله في القدس امام الكنيست
ساكون هناك
ماذا عن نتيجه هذه الدعوات لبن غفير شهدت
شوارع القدس اشتباكات بين مؤيدين ومعارضين
للتعديلات القضائيه
[موسيقى]
ومن القدس ينضم الينا مدير مكتب قناه
العربيه زياد حلبي اهلا بك معنا زياد يعني
شارع مقابل شارع المتظاهرين من اليمين
يشتبكون مع الشرطه الاسرائيليه احتجاجا
على تعليق التعديلات القضائيه ماذا في
التفاصيل
في التفاصيل هذه الليله بان الاحتجاجات
مستمره يعني على جانبي الازمه انجاز
التعبير هكذا
قاده الاحتجاجات ضد خطه الانقلاب على
القضاء كما يسمونها في اسرائيل اعلنوا بان
الاحتجاجات مستمره في تل ابيب تحديدا هناك
الان مظاهره كبيره محاولات متجدده لقطع
الشوارع الرئيسيه اشتباكات مع الشرطه
الاسرائيليه هناك التي تحاول منع اغلاق
الشوارع الرئيسيه في تل ابيب كما حدث
الليله الماضيه على المقلب الاخر في القدس
الغربيه ايضا بعد المظاهره الكبيره التي
كانت
للمحتجين او المعارضين لخطه نتنياهو 115
الفا شاركوا فيها جرت
مظاهره لليمين الاسرائيلي بمشاركه عشرات
الالاف ايضا كانت كبيره نسبيا في خلال هذه
جاءت مجموعه معروفه جدا في اسرائيل
بالتطرف والعنصريه اسمها لافاميليا هي من
اليمين الايدولوجي المتطرف جدا
وانهالت ضربا عمليا واعتداء على
المتظاهرين ضد نتنياهو تدخلت الشرطه
الاسرائيليه واشتبكت معهم بهذا المعنى ليس
دقيقا حاليا القول بان هناك شارع في مقابل
شارع لانه في نهايه المطاف الاغلبيه في
اسرائيل هي ضد هذه الخطه كما تبين
استطلاعات الراي هناك محاوله الان من
اليمين لحشد القوه على الارض في مواجهه
الاحتجاجات عمليا لكن باعتقاد لهذه الليله
نتنياهو لم يرد ان يرى النتائج التي
نشرت اليوم بالنسبه لاستطلاعات الراي
شعبيته انهارت تماما في اسرائيل معظم
الاسرائيليين يعتقدون بان اداءه سيء
للغايه وحتى ان بينيجانس يتقدم على في
الاكثر ملائمه عمليا على لان يكون رئيسا
للوزراء واغلبيه واضحه في الشارع
الاسرائيلي ضد اقاله وزير الدفاع جلند وضد
خطه نتنياهو بهذا المعنى ايضا هناك اغلبيه
تريد الحوار بين الاطراف والخروج
بصفقه توافقيه
لاصلاحات بهذا المعنى موقف الحكومه
ونتنياهو ما يزال معقدا في مواجهه الشارع
الاسرائيلي كان امله بان تقود هذه هذا
التعليق الى تخفيف وطئه الاحتجاجات ربما
حقق انجازا لجهه ان المعارضه تلقفت ذلك
وقالت انها مستعده للحوار لكن الشارع هو
من قرر في البدايه في البدايه ويقرر الان
نعله الامور على الارض
وبعيدا عن اسرائيل نذهب لمتابعه جانب من
جلسه مجلس الامن حول حادثه تفجير خط نور
ستريم نتابع معكم اذا كلمه المندوب الروسي
يزيد من
الدعوه الى تحقيق دوله ما كنا لنطلب
التحقيق الدولي لم يكن من اسباب موجبه
فعلا
لقد تحل الاتحاد الروسي بحس مسؤوليه كبير
وبمرونه كبيره في المشاورات اخذنا في
الحسبان مشاغل الدول التي شاركت في
المشاورات وندعو المجلس الى دعم مشروع
القرار هذا اذا ان اعتماده يسمح بارسال
رساله واضحه مفاه ان هذه الاعمال
التخريبيه لهياكل عابره للحدود غير مقبوله
وان المرتكبين سوف يسالون وهذا يصب في
مصلحه الجميع وفي مصلحه الاسره الدوليه
قاطبه وشكرا لحسن الانتباه
اشكر ممثل الاتحاد الروسي على هذا البيان
مجلس الامن مستعد الان للانتقال الى
التصويت على مشروع القرار المعروض عليه
اطرح الان مشروع القرار للتصويت
ادعو مؤيدي مشروع القرار الوارد في
الوثيقه اس على 2023 على
212 الى رفع اياته
شكرا
ادعو المعترضين على مشروع القرار الى رفع
اياديهم
والان ادعو الممتنعين عن التصويت الى رفع
شكرا لكم
نتيجه التصويت كالتالي
المؤيدون ثلاثه اصوات
المعترضون لا صوت امل ممتنعون عن تصفيه
عددهم 12
وعليه لم يعتمد مشروع القرار لكونه لم
يحصل على الرقم المطلوب من الاصوات
اعطي الكلمه الان لاعضاء المجلس الراغبين
في الادلاء ببيانات بعض التصويت اذا نكتفي
بهذا القدر من جلسه مجلس الامن التي كانت
تحت بند مشروع قرار بالقيام بتحقيق حول
حادثات النورستريم فشل اذا المقترح الروسي
الذي كانت طالبت به موسكو سابقا باجراء
تحقيق مستقل في تفجير خط نور ستريم
الاصوات هي ثلاثه اصوات مؤيده لاجراء
تحقيق واثني عشر معترضه
نعود لتطورات الوضع في اسرائيل حيث دعا
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي السابق بنيجانت
نتنياهو الى الحوار لحل ازمه التعديلات
القضائيه والتي تسببت بغليان في الحكومه
والشارع الاسرائيلي لم يكن يجب ان نصل الى
هذا الوضع انا اعارض هذه الحكومه وساستمر
كذلك طريق الحوار والتوافقات هو الطريق
الصحيح اطالب نتنياهو بان يرسل وفده
للحوار لنعمل على تعزيز الديمقراطيه
وتحسين اداء الحكومه وحمايه استقلاليه
المنظومه القضائيه ولن نتهاون في مبادئ
الديمقراطيه لان القانون اساس الحريات
اعلن قاده الاحتجاجات في اسرائيل
استمرارهم في الاحتجاج رغم تاجيل نتنياهو
لتعديلات القضائيه وقال قاده الاحتجاجات
ان نتنياهونار بتاجيل التعديلات من اجل
تمريرها لاحقا بعد اضعاف الضغط الشعبي
مشددين على انهم لن يبتلعوا الطعم في
المقابل اكد اتحاد العمال الاسرائيلي انه
علق الاضراب العام المعلن غدا
[موسيقى]
ومن القدس ينضم الينا بن مناحيم المحلل
السياسي اهلا بك معنا الليله سيد يوني
يعني امام هذا المشهد وهذه الحشود ان كان
المؤيده لنتنياهو ان كان المعارضه له
وللتعديلات القضائيه كيف يمكن تقييم خطوره
هذه الانقسامات التي نراها في الشارع
الاسرائيلي
هذا وضعي خطير جدا هذا
انقسام غير مسبوق في المجتمع الاسرائيلي
منذ قيام دوله اسرائيل ولكن انا اعتقد بان
خطاب نتنياهو الذي اعلن فيه ان تجميد كل
الاصلاحات القضائيه الجديده
كل سن هذه الاصلاحات في البرلمان
قد يخفف من حده التوتر بين المعسكرين
المعيد والمعاقد هذه الاصلاحات
وايضا
رغبه نتنياهو
استجابه
بني جانس
للحوار
حول الصيغه متفق عليها هذا قد يخفف من
المظاهرات والاحتجاجات علينا ان ننتظر
ونرى ماذا سيتطور في الايام القليله
المقبله نعم المعارضه رفضت سيد يونيو
المشاركه في هذا الحوار واعتبرته مناوره
وسيعاد هذا الملف لا يفتح واصلا حتى طريقه
كلام
نتنياهو كانت فيها اصرار بانه هذه
التعديلات وانا امتلك سلطه التعديل
التعديلات القضائيه لدي الاغلبيه في
الكنيست الاسرائيلي
علي هذه التصريحات انا حسب تقديري
للاستهلاك المحلي هو يقود الائتلاف
الحكومي والي ان يقنع
وسائل الاحزاب اليمينيه المتطرفه
ولذلك يتحدث بهذه الصوره ولكن انا اعتقد
تماما بانه لا يريد الاستمغاء في هذه
المرحله بهذه الطريقه في سن القوانين في
البرلمان ويريد
تجربه اخرى يريد ان يجرب
الحوار والمفاوضات مع الطرف الثاني
المشكله هي بان
رؤساء الحركه الاحتجاجيه
امم من البدايه يريدون اسقاط حكم نتنياهو
والتغيير نظام
اليمين في اسرائيل ولذلك
المشكله هي مشكله كبيره وعلينا ان نرى اذا
فعلا سينجح الحوار بين حزب الكود بين حزبي
ولا في بما انك تحدثت عن تغيير النظام
اليمين باسرائيل زعيم المعارضه
الاسرائيليه منذ قليل قال بانه يجب ان
نجلس معا ونكتب دستورا مستندا الى اعلان
الاستقلال يعني هنا لا نتحدث عن فقط
التخلي عن مشروع التعديلات القضائيه لا
نتحدث عن سقوط هذه الحكومه بل نتحدث عن
مشروع اكبر من ذلك عن تغيير الدستور
الاسرائيلي ونظام الحكم ربما
ليس هناك دستور في اسرائيل
هو يريد
التوسل الاتفاق حول دستور لاول مره في
اسرائيل ولكن هذا هذه المهمه هي مستحيله
تقريبا وليس واقعيه لماذا
لان كانت هناك محاولات منذ قيام دوله
اسرائيل وحتى اليوم
لتوسل الاتفاق حول دستور وكل المسايب بقت
بالفشل وهذا بسبب الخلافات بين الاحزاب
وخاصه
مع الاحزاب الدينيه
في هناك مسائل دينيه معقده ولذلك من الصعب
جدا التوصل الى الى دستور في اسرائيل
ولذلك انا اعتقد بانها
سيفهم بنهايه انه الشيء الوحيد ممكن ممكن
التوسل اليه هو صياغه بنود
السلاحات الجديده بتوافق مع لحزب الكود
هذا الشيء اللي هو ممكن الحصول عليه
نعم نعم شكرا جزيلا لك اذا من القدس
يونيحيم المحلل السياسي شكرا لك
نتنياهو خلال خطابه اليوم ورغم ارجاء
التعديلات اشار الى ان لدى ائتلافه
الاغلبيه في الكنيست تجعله يناقش
التعديلات القضائيه لكن هل ما قاله
نتنياهو صحيح لنلقي نظره على استطلاع
للراي نشرته صحيفه جيروزالي
والاستطلاع اشار الى انه في حال جرت
انتخابات للكنيسه الان ستخسر احزاب
الائتلاف الحاكم في اسرائيل ثمانيه مقاعد
من قوتها الحاليه على خلفيه خطتها لاضعاف
جهاز القضاء ووفقا للاستطلاع سيتراجع
تمثيل احزاب الائتلاف من 64 مقعدا حاليا
الى 56
وسيتراجع تمثيل حزب الليكود بقياده رئيس
الحكومه الحالي
باربعه مقاعد فيما سيتحصل او ستحصل
الاحزاب في المعارضه الحاليه على 64 مقعده
تراجع شعبيه الائتلاف الحاكم في اسرائيل
ليست مرتبطه فقط بقانون الاصلاح القضائي
فمنذ وصلت الحكومه قبل اشهر هناك نحو 141
قنونا اثار الجدل وواجه معارضه كبيره
اقاله نتنياهو لوزير الدفاع كان شراره اخر
فصول ثوره الشارع الاسرائيلي قانون اصلاح
القضاء كان سبب الرئيسي لكن الائتلاف
الحكومي اصدر 141 قرارا اخر قانون الدرعي
السماح للمدانين بتولي المناصب الوزاريه
قانون الحصانه تحصين الجنود من المتابعه
القضائيه
قانون الشرطه السماح للشرطه بتفتيش
المنازل دون ترخيص واضعاف الرقابه على عنف
عناصرها
قانون الهدايا السماح للموظفين بقبول
الهدايا مهما كانت قيمتها
القانون الفرنسي تحصين الرئيس من الملاحقه
القضائيه
دعا رئيس هيئه اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي
هرتسيها الجنود الى مواصله اداء واجباتهم
والتصرف بمسؤوليه في مواجهه الانقسامات
الاجتماعيه واضاف هذه ان هذه الاوقات
مختلفه عن اي اوقات شهدتها اسرائيل من قبل
مؤكدا ان الجيش يشهد اياما مليئه
بالتهديدات الخارجيه بينما تتشكل عاصفه في
الداخل
وكان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو قد دعى خلال كلمته قاده الجيش الى
مواجهه العصيان مؤكدا ان الجيش لا يمكن ان
يبقى برفض الخدمه العسكريه
هناك اقليه متطرفه تريد تمزيق اسرائيل
وتسحبنا لحرب اهليه نحن على مسار صدام في
المجتمع الاسرائيلي ولن نقبل بحرب اهليه
لا اقبل نداءات العصيان واطالب قياده
الجيش والاجهزه الامنيه ان يقفوا في وجه
حركه العصيان اطالب قاده الجيش بمواجهه
ظاهره رفض الخدمه العسكريه الجيش
الاسرائيلي لا يمكن ان يقبل برفض الخدمه
العسكريه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد توافد مستمر واعداد
كبيره للمعتمرين في خامس ايام شهر رمضان
المبارك امانه تمكن نشرت نحو 13
الف و600 عامل اضافه الى الف مراقب لتنفيذ
خطتها الموسميه منذ دخول شهر رمضان عبر
تقديم خدماتها في تشغيل وصيانه ونظافه
المرافق البلديه ومتابعه جاهزيتها والعمل
على شبكات الطرق والانفاق والاناره
والحدائق وغيرها من الخدمات
من مكه المكرمه ينضم الينا سلطان السلمي
مراسل العربيه اهلا بك معنا سلطان يعني
نشاهد من ورائك حافلات
والمعتمرين فلنتحدث عن نقل هذه الاعداد
الكبيره ما شاء الله يعني من المعتمرين
كيف تتم وايضا كيفيه اداره هذه الحشود
اهلا بك واهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه العربيه
بالفعل اعتمدت الجهات الخاصه والمعنيه
بخدمه المعتمرين والمصلين بالحرم المكي في
شهر رمضان هذا العام ونتحدثون عن القطاعات
الامنيه وكذلك قطعه النقل ورئاسه شؤون
الحرمين اريد ان اخذكم معنا في الصوره
مختلفه نشاهد مئات الحافله الحافلات التي
تصطف تجهيزا لنقل المصلين والمعتمرين بعد
الانتهاء من اداء صلاه التراويح اذا انتهت
الصلاه قبل دقائق من الان وهذه الحافلات
تنتظر هنا لنقل مئات الالاف من المعتمرين
والمصلين بعد الانتهاء من اداء صلوات
العشاء والتراويح نشاهد هذه الحافلات يتم
نقل معتمرين بها الى المحطات النقل الخمسه
التي تنتشر في العاصمه المقدسه ومن ثم
يستطيع المعتمر مصلي اخذ مركبته الخاصه
وحتى التوجه الى مساكنهم في مكه المكرمه
تعتمد القطاعات الامنيه لتنظيم عمليات
التنقل من والى الحرم المكي على قطاع
النقل العام ممثله في الحافلات بشكل رئيسي
جدا نتحدث على اعداد كبيره جدا يتم نقلها
يوميا طوال الساعات اليوم هنا في الحرم
المكي نتحدث عن 14
مسار تم تخصيصها من داخل الحرم المكي
ليستطيع المعتمر والمصلي التنقل عبر هذه
المسارات وصولا الى المحطات المجاوره
للحرم المكي من خلال يستطيع المعتمر مصلي
يعني استقلال هذه الحافلات والوصول بها
الى مقراتهم اذا تحدثنا عن الشوارع
الرئيسيه والشوارع المجاوره والمحاور
الرئيسيه المجاوره للحرم المكي تم تخصيصها
بعد صلاه العشاء وحتى الساعه الحاديه عشر
هي فقط للمشاه حتى يستطيع المعتمرين
والمصريين الخروج كما يظهر امامكم على
الكاميرا يستطيع المعتمر المصلي للخروج من
الحرم المكي بعد اداء صلاه التراويح ومن
ثم التوجه الى هذه الحافلات واستقلالها
ووصول الى محطات النقل كما نشاهد لا يوجد
اي
خاصه لقطاعه حكوميه او حتى مركبات خاصه
بالمدنيين صور قطاع المرور الذي يعمل على
تنظيم الحركه داخل هذه المنطقه المركزيه
من اكثر الاوقات ازدحاما في المنطقه
المركزيه هي بعد انتهاء صلاه التراويح كما
يظهر امامكم وهنا تعتمد عمليات التفويج
واداه الحشود الى ايصال المعتمرين
والمصلين الى هذه المحطات عبر مسارات خاصه
خصصتها نتحدث عن 14 مسار مخصص للمشاه
للمعتمرين في المنطقه المركزيه وصولا الى
المواقف الخاصه بهذه الحافلات لا يستطيع
المركبات الخاصه
مثل السيارات الاجره وغيرها الركوب منها
فقط حافلات النقل العامه التي توصل الى
محطات العامه التي تقع بالقرب من الحرم
المكي تحدثنا عن المدد الزمنيه الخاصه من
والى الحرم المكي لا تتجاوز 16 دقيقه
عمليات النقل خاصه بالمعتمرين والمص الى
هذه المحطات نتحدث عن اكثر من 3000 حافله
متواجده يوميه لنقل المعتمرين على مدار
الساعه طوال ساعات اليوم ايضا من المهم
انه عمليات النقل هذه تخفف بشكل كبير
عمليات التكدس الخاصه بمركبات في المنطقه
المركزيه او حتى في الشوارع الرئيسيه
والفرعيه المقابله للحرم المكي وهذه
النقطه خففت كثيرا عمليات التكدس وعمليات
الزحام وهي الاسهل وهي اكثر مرونه لوصول
المعتمرين الى مساكينما او حتى محطه
التوقف هذه الحافلات هي بالمجان تم تخصيص
حافلات مكه وكذلك غيرها من حافلات النقل
العام نتحدث على اكثر من 420 محطه تنتشر
في العاصمه المقدسه يستطيع من خلالها
الركوب المعتمره والمصلي من والى الحرم
المكي عبر خطط وخطه تنفيذيه رئيسيه عملت
عليها خطوط النقل للاستفاده منها هذا
العام شكرا جزيلا لك اذا من مكه المكرمه
سلطان السلمي مراسل العربيه
[موسيقى]
كشفت مصادر لي رويترز ان لجنه المحلفين
الخاصه بقضيه رئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب في منهاتن ستجتمع اليوم حيث يواجه
ترامب العديد من القضايا عاليه المخاطر
ابرزها قضيه دفع اموال صامته
لاحدى النجمات او الممثلات وهو ما سيجعله
اول رئيس امريكي يواجه تهمه جنائيه لكن
ترامب لديه استراتيجيه
عاصفه قضائيه وسياسيه بطلها دونالد ترامب
الذي يحاول مع اقتراب موعد حملته الرئاسيه
الثالثه اتباع استراتيجيه قانونيه جديده
لمواجهه التحقيقات والاتهامات التي تطاله
الرئيس الامريكي السابق ومع التقدم
التحقيقات بات يستخدم تكتيكات التشتيت
التي تعتمد على المماطله وتشويه سمعه
المدعين العامين واللجوء ايضا الى القاعده
الجمهوريه وفق تقرير صادر عن وولد
تحدثت فيه الصحيفه مع مساعدين حاليين
وسابقين للترامب الصحيفه دللت على هذا
التكتك بتصعيد ترامب لهجومه على المدعي
العام لمحكمه منهاتان خصوصا وان قرارها قد
يؤدي الى اعتقاله في قضيه جنائيه وهي
سابقه في تاريخ الولايات المتحده
ومن تكساس هجم المحققين ووصف نفسه بانه
ضحيه وقال ان تسليح نظام العداله هو
القضيه المركزيه في العصر الحالي ووفق
التقرير قام ترامب بتشكيل مجموعه تضم
مستشارين قانونيين ومحامين ساعيا لتاجيل
الاجراءات القضائيه ومهاجمه اي تهم محتمله
لكن الفريق يفتقر للتنسيق والتنظيم امر
نفاه محامي ترامبا السابق هذا الامر تطرقت
اليه مجله فرنسيه التي اشارت الى ان سجلات
لجنه الانتخابات الفيدراليه اظهرت بان
لجنه العمل السياسيه التابعه للترامب دفعت
اكثر من 16 مليون دولار في رسوم
الاستشارات القانونيه عامي 2021
و2022 ذهب اكثر من نصفها الى شركات مرتبطه
بالمحامين الذين يمثلون ترامب في تحقيقات
مختلفه وفي وقت يواجه فيه ترامب العديد من
القضايا ينفي انصاره كل هذه الاتهامات
التي وصفوها بالقضايا السياسيه اكثر من
كونها قانونيه
[موسيقى]
ابسط هيئه حكوميه بولنديه بحذر استخدام
تطبيق تيك توك على هواتف موظفي الاداره
العامه وبحسب الهيئه فان التوصيات ليست
ملزمه للحكومه لكنها اشارت في الوقت ذاته
الى ايجابيه ازاله التطبيق الصيني من
هواتف العمل
وقبل اشهر حضر البرلمان الاوروبي تطبيق
تيك توك الصينيعا هواتف موظفيه لاسباب
امنيه لكن هذا القرار يواجه الان اعتراضا
من قبل برلمانيين اوروبيين وخاصه مع قرب
اجراء انتخابات عام 2024
على وقع مخاوف امنيه موظف البرلمان
الاوروبي امروا بازاله تطبيق تيك توك من
هواتفهم المحموله لكن القرار لم يلق قبولا
لدى موظفي البرلمان الاوروبي ضاربين
بتهديدات الامن السيبراني المزعومه عرض
الحائط
البرلمان الاوروبي امر موظفي بازاله تيك
توك من الاجهزه المستخدمه في العمل بسبب
مخاوف وتتعلق بحمايه البيانات اعتراض
البرلمانيين الاوروبيين على ازاله تطبيق
تيك توك خرج الى وسائل الاعلام الذين عزوا
موقفهم بان التطبيق الصيني يمكنه من
الوصول الى الشباب وتحديدا جنسي الذي يشكل
قاعده جماهيريه كبيره وبالاخص مع قرب
اجراء انتخابات عام 2024
هناك اكثر من 125 مليون اوروبي يستخدم تيك
توك بنشاط كل شهر كما للتطبيق شعبيه لدى
المشرعين الاوروبيين انفسهم حتى ان المشرع
الالماني مالتي جالي لديه ما يصل الى 36
الف متابع التحول في موقف الاتحاد
الاوروبي من التطبيق الصيني جاء بعد بضعه
اشهر فقط بعدما كان 14 مسؤولا قد وافقوا
رسميا على اطلاق حساب موثق عبر تيك توك
[موسيقى]
المستشار الالماني انا برلين سلمت
اوكرانيا دبابات لوبارده وكانت صحيفه ديل
الالمانيه قد افادت بوصول 18 دبابه 2 الى
اوكرانيا من المانيا تم تسليمها على
الحدود الاوكرانيه كما اضافت ونقل
الدرشبيل عن مصادر قولهم ان برلين سلمت 40
مدرعه من طراز ماردر الى كيف ايضا
وتستمر المعارك في شرق اوكرانيا بين طرفي
الصراع ففي الوقت الذي تصعد وتصعد القوات
الروسيه من قصفها لمدينه ابياتفيكا سعيا
للسيطره عليها بدات السلطات الاوكرانيه
باجلاء موظفها
مشاهد الدمار والخراب توحي بان الصور من
فيلم سينمائي عن نهايه العالم لكن الحال
يؤكد انه من واقع بوابه اقليم دونيتس
كالصناعي في الجزء الجنوبي من ضخموت
الحديث هنا عن التي تشهد قصفا مدفعيا
مكثفا السيطره على المدينه الواقعه على
مسافه 13 كيلومترا فقط عن دوناتسك تتيح
للجيش الروسي قطع خط امداد القوه
الاوكرانيه في الشرق وسيسمح لموسكو باحكام
قبضتها في جنوب وشرق اوكرانيا وضمان تامين
خطوط امداد لوجيستيه للجيش ومع اشتداد
المعارك السلطات الاوكرانيه بدات في سحب
موظفي البلديه من المدينه الجيش الاوكراني
يحاول التمسك بالمواقع الحاليه وصد
الهجمات الروسيه لحين تزويد تلك الجبهه في
السلاح
خبراء روس يصفون استراتيجيه كياب وحلفائها
لمحاوله ارهاق واستنزاف روسيا في الجبهه
الشرقيه بالفاشله فالجيش الروسي يسيطر على
اكثر من 60% من مساحه بخموت وتحديدا القسم
الشرقي الشرقي نهر بخموتكي اضافه الى
الاحياء الجنوبيه والشماليه وكل الطرق
الواصله الى بخمو تحت السيطره الروسيه
باستثناء طريق واحد للسماح بخروج الجيش
الاوكراني وفي حال سقطت ضخمه بالكامل
وسيطره موسكو على
فان هذا سيسمح للروس بتنفيذ تقدم عسكري
بوتيره سريعه وعلى مساحات واسعه وسقوط
المدن الكبرى في دونتسك وفق خبراء عسكريين
قام متحف اللوفر ابوابه امام الزوار
العاصمه الفرنسيه
فذلك
في اضراب للمطالبه بالغاء اصلاح نظام
تقاعد الذي اعادته الحكومه واكدت اداره
متحف اللوفر على صفحتها على تويتر اغلاق
المتحف بسبب الاضراب الذي غطى جميع
القطاعات في فرنسا تقريبا
وفي المانيا توقفت حركه النقل البري
والجوي والماء بشكل كامل في المانيا في
يوم اضراب دعت اليه نقابات عماليه للضغط
على مشغل القطارات والمطار لزياده رواتب
موظفين
ما زالت الادراج الكهربائيه في محطه برلين
الرئيسيه للقطارات تعمل رغم انها توصلنا
وتوصل المسافرين هنا الى منصه قطارات
فارغه لا تتوقفوا فيها القطارات ولا
تغادرها
وكان الساعه تتوقفت هنا
اطفئت لوحه اعلاناتي توقيت القطارات وغاب
المسافرون الذين يقصدون هذه المحطه عاده
للسفر الى مختلف المدن الالمانيه
والاوروبيه فالاضراب الذي دعت اليه
نقابتان عماليتان في المانيا تمثلان قرابه
الثلاثه ملايين موظف شل حركه القطارات
والطيران في معظم المدن الالمانيه وتحرك
بالقطارات بات مستحيلا وفرض على الكثيرين
تغيير خطط سفرهم
من جهتنا الامر مقبول ولكن من جهه اخرى لا
اجد الامر جيدا علينا ان نبحث عن فندق
جديد لاننا غادرنا فندقنا اليوم وايضا
الان علينا استبدال بطاقه القطار التي كنا
اشتريناها للسفر اليوم
نحن هنا اليوم لانه عيد ميلادي واردنا
زياره بوتساب فانا هنا للسياحه وجئنا بحثا
عن قطار ولكن لم نتمكن من اللحاق به
وعلينا الان ان نجد وسيله بديله ولكن
الموظفين المضربين لديهم اسبابهم للاضراب
مسافرون فرنسيون كانوا اكثر تفهما لحركه
الاضراب يده التي اراد منظمها ان تحاكي
التحركات في فرنسا اجد ان مطالبهم لتغطيه
التضخم واؤيد الموظفين رغم معرفه بان هذا
يؤثر على المسافرين ولكن لو كان هذا الحل
لكي يحصل على مبتغاهم انا اؤيدهم النقابات
العمليه تطالب بزياده رواتب موظفي سكك
الحديد والمطارات بنسبه تتراوح بين 10
ونصف بالمئه واثني عشره لكي تعوض عن
التضخم الذي زادت نسبته على التسعه في
المئه الشهر الماضي وهي تحذر من ان الشلل
الذي اصيبت به البلاد هذا اليوم ليس الا
البدايه في حال لم يتم التواصل الاتفاقا
حول زياده الاجور راغده بهنام العربيه
برلين
دا فاز سكراتار مجلس الوزراء للعدل حمزه
يوسف زعامه الحزب الوطني
المتوقع ان يخلف يوسف نيكولاس تورجون
وزيرا اولا لاسكتلندا اثراء تصويت سيتم
غدا في البرلمان في ادنبره
[تصفيق]
حمزه يوسف اول زعيم اسكتلنديا مسلم بعد
انتخابه زعيما للحزب الوطني لاسكتلندي
تمهيدا لخلافه نيكولا المستقيله كوزير اول
لاسكتلندا حمزه يوسف ابن ابوين هاجر من
باكستان الى غلاسكو في ستينات القرن
الماضي ووصوله الى اعلى منصب سياسي في
اسكتلندا لم يكن صدفه نظرا لتجاربه
السياسيه في عده مناصب وزاريه ما سيضع في
التعامل مباشر مع رئيس وزراء بريطانيا
لمواجهه التحديات البلاد
لا اعتقد انه سيكون هناك اي توتر ملحوظ
بين القائدين على الرغم من انه بالطبع وضع
رائع بالنظر الى تاريخ الامبراطوريه
البريطانيه وهو بالتاكيد شيء يجب الاحتفال
به وشيء مثير للاهتمام وان كان هناك ما
سيقرب القائدين من بعضهما البعض فقد تكون
الخلفيه العرقيه والتجارب المتشابهه في
حياتهما خلال نش اتهما في المملكه المتحده
تعهدات حمزه يوسف بما فيها تحقيق ما فشلت
فيه سلفه بعقد استفتاء لاستقلال اسكتلندا
عن المملكه المتحده والانضمام الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي سيشكل النقطه الخلافيه الكبرى مع
الحكومه في لندن القائدان السوناك وحمزه
في مسار مواجهه شرسه بشان استقلال
اسكتلندا وموقف الحكومه البريطانيه ثابت
لحمايه دول الاتحاد البريطاني
افهم تماما السياق التاريخيه امامنا
واعتقد انه لا توجد اي طبقات اخرى من
الصراع ليست موجوده بالفعل فيما يتعلق
بالقوميه الاسكتلنديه فانه يجب الاحتفال
بالتنوع العرقي والتوتر مع حكومه المملكه
المتحده مستمر منذ عقود ولا اعتقد ان هذا
سيكون مختلفا في المستقبل
اقليه عرقيه الان اصبحت تدير الشؤون
الاغلبيه من البيض في اسكتلندا وباقي
الاراضي البريطانيه
الزعيم الاسكتلندي حمزه يوسف هو رئيس
الوزراء البريطانيه من ابناء مهاجرين
قدموا من مستعمرات الامبراطوريه
البريطانيه السابقه وصولهما الى اعلى
المناصب السياسيه يعكس نجاح نموذج
الاندماج في بلد كان يحكم ارض اجدادهما
العربيه لندن
حمزه يوسف الرئيس الجديد للحزب الوطني
الاسكتلندي مسلم من اصول باكستانيه ولد في
مدينه جلاسكو يوم السابع ابريل
1985 درس بجامعه وحصل على الماجستير في
العلوم السياسيه سنه 2007 عام 2011 تم
انتخابه في البرلمان عن منطقه جلاسكو عام
2012 تم تعيينه في منصب كاتب الدوله
بوزاره الشؤون الخارجيه والعلاقات الدوليه
عام 2016 تم تعيينه وزيرا للنقل عام 2018
تقلد منصب وزير العدل الى عام 2021
عام 2021 تسلم منصب وزير الصحه والعمل
الاجتماعي عام 2023 فاز برئاسه الحزب
الوطني الاسكتلندي
افادت شرطه مدينه ناشفير بولايه تنسى
بمقتل سبعه اشخاص على الاقل بعمليه اطلاق
نار في مدرسه بالمدينه بينهم منفذ الهجوم
كما قالت سلطات الولايه ان الحادث اسفر عن
عده اصابات تعاملت معها اجهزه الاسعاف من
هذه اعلن البيت الابيض ان الرئيس جو بايدن
سيتحدث بعد قليل حول الحادثه
[موسيقى]
في لبنان وبعد العاصفه التي اثارت اثارتها
اثرها موضوع التعديل
الساعه تراجعت الحكومه اللبنانيه عن
استمرار العمل بالتوقيت الشتوي لكن ماذا
تغير خلال 24 ساعه لتغير الحكومه قرارها
مصدر مطلع للعربيه كشف ان صفقه مشبوهه هي
التي وقفت وراء مساله اختلاف التوقيت في
لبنان حيث تمرير صفقه لسيارات مسؤولين
لبنانيين خلال ضجيج التوقيتين ففي الوقت
الذي انشغل فيه اللبنانيون بقضيه
التوقيتين جرى تعديل خاص للدولار الجمركي
للسيارات على اساس 8000 ليره بدل الخمسه
واربعين الفا المعبول المعمول بها حاليا
اوضح المصدر ايضا ان قانون الموازنه
الاخير حدد مبلغ 8000 ليره لجمارك
السيارات المستورده وابقى العمل بهذا
القرار حتى الاول من فبراير الماضي على ان
يعدل المبلغ بعد هذا التاريخ ليصبح 45000
اشار المصدر الى التعديل القرار حصل وتم
تمديد العمل به من الواحد او الاول من
فبراير الى الاول من مارس شرط ان تكون
السيارات قد شحنت قبل الاول من مارس بغض
النظر عن تاريخ دخولها الحرم الجمركي غير
ان اللافت بقرار التمديد بحسب المصدر انه
اتخذ يوم الجمعه الماضي اي نفس يوم الذي
قررت فيه الحكومه تاخير اعتماد التوقيت
الصيفي وهو ما لم تنفه مصادر الجمارك
الى العراق وبعد شد وجدر استمر عده اسابيع
صوت البرلمان العراقي على تعديل قانون
الانتخابات باغلبيه مريحه وسط تلويح القوى
الرافضه باللجوء الى الشرح
يدخلون العسكر هذا خلال بالنظام في جلسه
عاصفه استمرت حتى الفجر شهدت اعتراض
وانسحاب الكتل البرلمانيه المستقله صوت
البرلمان العراقي على تعديل قانون
الانتخابات تعديل وصفته القوى المعارضه
بانه تكريس لسيطره الاحزاب الكبيره على
الدوره المقبله للبرلمان وتغييب للتيارات
الديمقراطيه المستقله تمرير قانون مرفوض
حقيقه من قبل الشعب ومن قبل المرجعيه هو
تمرد على الشعب حقيقه من صوت على ستكون
بدايه النهايه له اذا الشعب يوما اراد
الحياه فلابد ان يستجيب القدر هنا قدرنا
ان نذهب معارضه وطنيه واعيه حقيقيه ما هي
ابرز التعديلات التي اجريت على قانون
الانتخابات العوده الى قانون 2018 الذي
رفضته حركه تشرين الاحتجاجيه عام 2019 كل
محافظه ستعد دائره انتخابيه واحده اي 18
دائره بدلا من 83 دائره التي اعتمدت في
الانتخابات الاخيره التعديلات الجديده تصب
في صالح القوى السياسيه الكبيره ولا تمنح
المستقلين فرصه في المنافسه اعاده تحديث
سجل الناخبين في كركوك بعد تسويه بين
قومياتها العربيه والتركمانيه والكرديه
اعاده العمل بالعد والفرز اليدوي تعديل
قانون الانتخابات والتصويت عليه بهذه
الصيغه ما كان ليتم لولا وجود اتفاق بين
القوى السياسيه الشيعيه والسنيه والكرديه
حينما استقرت كل هذه الفتره
واحكمت قبضتها على المشهد السياسي لم تكن
من فراغ بالاتت من اتفاق سياسي اهداء لا
تكوين ائتلاف اداره الدوله وبالتالي تكوين
الحكومه وهذا هو ما ادى اليوم الى ان مر
القرن بهذه الاريحيه بغياب التيار الصدري
وربما معارضه الاحزاب المستقله والصغيره
اقر البرلمان العراقي تعديل قانون
الانتخابات الذي ستجرى بموج به الانتخابات
المحليه المتوقعه في نوفمبر المقبل من
بغداد منتظر رشيد العربيه
[موسيقى]
يوجد لسور القدس سبعه ابواب مفتوحه واربعه
مغلقه لكن باب العمود اكبرهم واكثرهم شهره
ويعد الباب الرئيسي المؤدي للمسجد الاقصى
يتزين في شهر رمضان بالفوانيس والاضواء
ويتوافد المئات مئات الالاف من المسلمين
اليه حيث يعتبره الفلسطينيون ارثا وطنيا
ومتنفسا لهم في هذا الشهر الفضيل
[موسيقى]
هنا باب العمود اضخم البوابات الرئيسيه
للبلده القديمه بالقدس بارتفاع يبلغ
ثمانيه امتار اكثرهم ثراء من حيث الزخارف
ويعود اسمه الى الفتره الرومانيه حيث تم
وضع عمود من الرخام الاسود يصل ارتفاعه
ضعف ارتفاع الباب في الساحه الداخليه وتم
استخدام العمود كاداه لقياس بعد مسافات
الدول والمدن عن مدينه القدس وللباب اسم
اخر اقل تداولا هو باب دمشق لانه كان
الباب الذي تخرج منه القوافل التجاريه الى
دمشق
وللباب اجواء رمضانيه خاصه حيث يتزين
بالاضواء والفوانيس ويتوافد عشرات الالاف
من المسلمين للدخول من هذا الباب وصولا
للمسجد الاقصى ويجلس المئات على درجات باب
العمود لتناول الحلويات بعد الافطار من
البسطات او حتى لتناول وجبه السحور قبل
الفجر لا نقل غاصي من القدس العربيه كره
العربيه مشاهدينا ايام تحديدا من ملعب
ستانفورد بريدج الخاص بناديه تشيلسي حيث
حفل افطار جماعي للصائمين اقامه النادي
ليكون الاول الذي يقام في خطوه قام بها
اذا الدوري الانجليزي الرساله من هذا
الافطار الجماعي ليست مجرد اقامته بل هي
رساله لتقبل الاخر واحترام دينه وثقافته
والتعايش معه في سلام وتوفير مساحه امنه
للحوار والمشاركه المتبادله طبعا هذه
الرساله ظهرت بوضوح على ملامح الصائمين من
كل الجنسيات
اما تصريح اليوم فهو لرئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيليه بين يمينه ثانيه قال المحتجون
وطنيون لكن لا يفهمون الاصلاح الذي ادعو
اليه لنفترض صحه حديث نتنياهو مشاهدينا
بتطبيقه على 100 شخص مثلا لكن هل اكثر من
115 الف شخص اليوم فقط في محيط الكنيستر
عاد طبعا عن بقيه المناطق لا يفهمون ربما
اراد نتنياهو ايصال رساله لمعارضيه اكثر
منها للمحتاجين او انها كانت زلت لسان لما
يعيشه من ضغوطات ايا كانت النيه وايام كان
مستقبل هذه الرساله الاكيده ان تصريح
نتنياهو سيعمل ضده وايام الحكومه باتت
معدوده رغم تاجيل مشروع التعديلات
القضائيه
نبقى في اسرائيل حيث نشاهد هذه الصور
لاشتباكات بين الشرطه
والمحتاجين الرافدين لتعليق الاصلاحات
القضائيه ونرى استعل استعمالا لخراطيم
المياه لرشق المحتجين
[موسيقى]
الى فيديو اليوم وهو من فرنسا وتحديدا من
شمالها الغربي بلده
في بريطانيا المئات تجمعوا هذه المره ليس
اعتراضا على قانون رفع سن التقاعد ولكن
متنكرين بشخصيات مسلسل الرسوم المتحركه
الشهير السنافر والهدف غريب بعض الشيء
تحطيم الرقم القياسي العالمي لاكبر تجمع
على الاطلاق للسنافر هل هو جنون المشاركون
يصفون نفسهم بذلك لكنهم مبتهجون ويعيشون
خلال هذه الاوقات قليله من المرح في بلد
يعج بالتظاهرات التي تشهد اشتباكات واحداث
عنيفه
[موسيقى]
والان الى زميله ميسون نويد واخبار الساعه
طبعا الملف الاسرائيلي والاحتجاجات هي ملف
اساسي مساء الخير راويه طبعا التطورات في
اسرائيل ستتصدر نشرتنا وجل هذه النشره
عنها بالاضافه الى بعض الاخبار عن التعديل
قانون الانتخاب من قبل البرلمان العراقي
ايضا لدينا التطورات المعارك في اوكرانيا
والاضرابات في المانيا تفضلوا ان تتابعينا
تفضل